Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
You posted a question.
I'm a cybernetic organism,
living tissue.
This episode is brought to you by wordpress.com I love wordpress.
I have used it for so many years.
It's my goto platform for blogging and creating websites.
I use wordpress.com for everything every day.
My site,
tim.blog is built on it.
The websites for my books,
including tools of titans,
tribe of mentors.
It's all in wordpress.com and the founder Matt Mullenweg.
When my close friends has appeared on this show,
many times,
just search Matt Mullenweg,
Tequila Ferris for quite an exciting time.
Whether you're looking to create a personal blog,
a business site,
or both,
you can make a really big impact right out of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and you'll be in good company.
It's used by the New Yorker,
Jay Z,
Beyonce,
five 38 tech crunch,
Ted,
CNN,
and time just to name a handful,
and one of my friends@googlewhoshallremainnamelesshastoldmethatwordpress.com
offers the best out of the box SEO imaginable end quote,
and it's one of the many reasons that nearly 30% of the Internet is run on
wordpress.
You do not need experience or to hire someone that's perhaps the best part.
wordpress.com guide you through the entire experience.
They have hundreds of designs and templates that you can use and it's easy to
get started.
There's no need to worry about security upgrades,
hosting any of that.
They have for 24 seven support and they're very,
very responsive.
If you have questions,
they get right back to you.
And this allows you to create the highest quality with the least amount of
headache and friction.
So if you're building a website,
period,
when my friends come to me and ask what I use,
what I recommend they use,
the answer is wordpress.com so check it out.
If you want to get started today,
learn more with a 15% discount off any new plan.
Go to wordpress.com forward slash Tim to create your website and find the plan
that's right for you.
So learn more.
Take a look,
wordpress.com forward slash Tim for 15% off a brand new website.
Check it out.
This episode is brought to you by legal zoom.
I have used legal zoom myself for many of my businesses and many of the icons on
this podcast have actually used legal zoom.
For instance,
Matt Mullenweg of wordpress fame CE of automatic,
which is now worth more than a billion dollars first incorporated his company on
legal zoom.
Legal Zoom is a reliable resource that more than a million people have already
trusted to help with their businesses.
Whether that's setting up a will,
doing a proper trademark search,
forming an LLC,
setting up a nonprofit,
or finding simple cease and desist letter templates.
Man do I use a lot of those?
Legal Zoom is not a law firm,
but they do have a network of independent attorneys available in most states.
They can give you advice on the best way to get started,
provide contract reviews in otherwise help you run your business and important.
There are no surprises.
Legal Zoom provides complete transparency.
That means upfront pricing,
customer reviews,
and a satisfaction guarantee.
Checkout Legal zoom.com today to see how they can make life better and easier
for you and your business.
If you're pretending to be a lawyer on the Internet,
then you are asking for trouble.
Put together the safety nets.
Get your t's crossed and your I's dotted.
Enter Promo Code Tim tim@legalzoom.com to save 15% that's t I m for 15% off.
Check it out.
Legal zoom.com
hello ladies and gentlemen and Hello Claris.
You'll see why that's relevant in a minute.
Welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
More specifically.
Welcome to another edition of the Tim Ferriss Radio Hour where I share some of
the habits and patterns of world class performers that I've identified.
After nearly 300,
300 guests on this podcast,
this episode,
we will explore fear,
specifically managing,
mitigating,
overcoming,
which is something I've personally spent decades battling with,
of course,
sometimes being paralyzed by,
and fortunately in more recent years,
more and more overcoming,
and this has been such a focal point of my life,
uh,
for extended periods that my last tedtalk focused on an exercise called fear
setting,
which is something that I have found to be a life raft.
And that I practice,
I would say at least once every month.
And you can learn more about that at Tim dot.
Blog forward slash ted if you want to see it.
It's all free and all specked out for you.
But aside from my personal experience coming up,
I'll discuss many different facets of fear or listen to tips and tactics and so
on from folks such as Sir Richard Branson,
founder and chairman of the Virgin Group.
So Richard is of course,
a world famous entrepreneur.
Adventure activists in business icon,
his most recent book finding my virginity shares the candid details of a
lifetime of triumphs and failures and it provides an intimate look at his quest
to push boundaries and that often includes breaking rules,
seeking new frontiers and certainly fear.
I suppose the most notable is this failure that we've ever had was taking on
Coda with Virgin Cola and for awhile it really looked like we were going to
topple coke.
Um,
absolutely.
I mean we were outselling them.
Then I talked to Maria Sharapova who's the winner of five Grand Slam tennis
titles and that sense of wow,
everyone all of a sudden once something,
everyone wants something
that you have,
everyone wants to be a part of your success.
I also discussed the relationship between courage and fear with movie star
director and producer Vince Vaughn.
I would get down and I would take four or five days and I would just not do
anything and I'd lose my energy.
Caroline Paul is our last guest.
She is an author who has worked as a journalist and who also became one of the
first female firefighters with the San Francisco Fire Department.
And I look around and there was just three of us instead of four.
And I remember thinking I have to go back into that hallway and the,
the fear was paralyzing.
So without further ado,
let's jump into it and we can begin with a bit of personal context.
On my part.
For most of my life I would say the driving values,
if you will have been security and lack of vulnerability.
So it's been a very defensive posture for very,
very long portion of my life.
Not all of it,
but optimizing was done to maximize security,
decreased vulnerability.
And as was told to me recently by Tony Robbins who have had the privilege to get
to know over the last few years,
there are some values that the more we obsess over them and fixate on them,
the less we perceive we have them.
And those could be values or resources.
For example,
you have respect or you have security.
The more you fixate on those things,
the less you perceive you have a,
because you put on a lens through which you see constantly the transgressions,
the slights,
the violations and so on.
And if you are trying to,
in my case,
say control everything for very long time,
the pro and con list,
the analytics,
the spreadsheets,
all of that was to try to control as many variables as possible.
And there is a place for control.
But when you try to control everything as I did for a very long time and still
sometimes do,
you end up in a position where you can be dominated by fear and or you can feel
helpless.
And this has led me over decades to experience many extended depressive periods.
That has led to having a very close brush with suicide and college,
uh,
which then led to the fear setting exercise that I mentioned earlier.
And all of that for people interested are spelled out both in text and video,
all for free at Tim Dot.
Blog Ford Slash Ted.
But I don't try to figure it all out on my own.
That is mistake that I've made repeatedly in the past and I've tried to get
better at asking for help and asking experts to explain how they handle the ups
and downs,
the triumphs and the failures,
the fear of the unknown and so on.
That allows me to assemble a toolkit of reminders and principles.
Beliefs may be phrases that I can revisit on a regular basis.
This is part of the reason why I ask so many of my guests about their failures
and fierce,
so let's jump to Sir Richard Branson.
Richard Branson on Twitter and mostly everywhere else is an English business
magnate investor and philanthropist.
He founded the virgin group which controls more than 400 companies.
Boggles the mind really to even think about that.
I have a long history with Sir Richard's books all the way back to losing my
virginity,
which I brought with me.
I still own it to this day after college.
And it helped to inspire one of my first businesses and his most recent book
finding my virginity,
which shares the details of,
as I mentioned before,
many of his triumphs and failures,
both of which on either end of the spectrum have been spectacular.
There've been so many really,
really incredibly,
uh,
noteworthy failures in Sir Richard's life.
We discussed his quest to push the boundaries,
stay high life and in the process conquer fear.
When you felt overwhelmed or unfocused,
uh,
or if you feel like you've temporarily lost your focus,
what do you do or what have you found to help?
Uh,
you know,
what questions do you ask yourself?
Is there,
in those cases,
what have you done historically that is,
that has been helpful?
You know,
I personally believe that the majority of people have down send their lives.
They can,
they can actually trace it back quite often to alcohol,
you know,
so perhaps the early days of my life that I feel lethargic is instead of having
two glasses at nighttime,
I had five or six.
And if I find that it's happened on more than one or two occasions,
I then give up completely for a month or two and,
uh,
and feel absolutely fantastic of course,
and realized that I'm never going to drink another touch about all the gain
until actually you do.
And,
and,
um,
you know,
fortunately,
I,
yeah,
I'm so busy that I,
I just can't afford to let myself down too often.
But my guess is that,
um,
yeah,
for the vast majority of people,
you know,
if you can,
if you can be high on life and fit and healthy and,
uh,
and you know,
if you do find that,
um,
there's something like alcohol is,
uh,
is,
is just the beginning.
You're beginning subject,
you'd get go a bit too far.
Uh,
you know,
being high on life is just so wonderful.
In essence.
Oh,
for a friend of mine,
a entrepreneur named Matt Mullenweg,
he's been on this podcast as well.
He's the CEO of a company called automatic,
which is behind wordpress,
which powers around 37% of the Internet right now.
And,
uh,
he told me at one point that he had learned something along ago,
which,
uh,
alcohol is borrowing happiness from tomorrow and certainly seems to be the case.
I think that there's a,
there's a,
there's a beautiful words and they're very,
very,
very true.
Um,
you know,
my son is just had a yet alcohol and,
and,
you know,
look,
you can tell he's just so high on a lot.
He's just enjoying,
enjoying it.
Like I like he's never enjoyed it before and,
and you know,
so like if you could do it in moderation,
that's great.
Uh,
you know,
I tell the story in the book,
there was one,
one night and when we,
when we won the Grand Prix in Melbourne,
and,
um,
anyway,
I let my hair down to such an extent that it would have made the film hangover
look like a children's children's film.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the next day I woke up and anyway,
I gave,
I gave up for six months.
And so it,
yeah,
it doesn't happen to me too often.
Um,
but,
um,
but I think Jen,
generally the gets,
yeah.
Generally when that's the one area that I think a lot of a lot of people they
do,
you don't run into problems that lives.
It's just such slightly too much.
Well,
during those periods when you go off alcohol,
do you avoid circumstances where other people are drinking or is there something
that you say to people if you are in those circumstances,
how do you ensure that you don't have just that one drink that then triggers
more drinks?
If you're trying to take time away from alcohol
is simply to have a cranberry and soda in a champagne glass.
People don't know.
I just want to take primary decider in the champagne glass then.
But I think,
look,
I think for a lot of people,
especially when people first to give up anything like that,
drugs,
alcohol,
they need to walk away completely for a while.
Fortunately,
I haven't gotten into,
I've never let myself get to that,
that,
that stage,
but you know,
but I think that,
you know,
the best advice is to get,
get getting,
you know,
just,
just say I need to go to bed early tonight and walk away.
Um,
otherwise it's very difficult to people to stay with it all.
You saw you,
are you somebody who drinks or not?
Uh,
I don't drink a whole lot.
I do enjoy wine.
Fortunately,
I don't feel like I've had any,
um,
issues with alcohol,
although genetically my family seems to have that predisposition.
Certainly have a fair amount of alcoholism and Mike extended family.
So I do,
I think about it quite a bit.
I can,
I can tell that I think I have the potential to abuse it,
but I haven't up to this point.
I think that you and not,
you and I have such fascinating lives that you know,
that,
that that is the best way of keeping,
you know,
keeping these sorts of things in check.
You know,
we just,
we want every day is so interesting that I'm just not going want to waste waste
today.
Right.
You know,
let,
let me get something like that and take over your life.
Right.
No,
definitely.
And,
uh,
just,
just two more questions for me.
This is one really intended just to give people a window into how you cope with
some of the harder times.
Uh,
do you have a favorite failure of yours?
And what I mean by that is,
uh,
how has a failure or an apparent failure set you up for later success?
Are there any particular examples that come to mind?
Yeah,
I mean,
I think old me and,
uh,
on the adventure side,
you the test.
I'm we the Atlantic and um,
we are trying to break the record for the pastors across the Atlantic and
getting the new ribbon back and um,
you know,
and we sank.
And then the next day we built another boat and we were successful.
And the British people love people who are underdogs.
And,
uh,
and it taught me that actually failing and then being successful,
most likely he was better than just going out there and being successful the
first time round.
I mean,
it is overcoming difficulties,
uh,
the public almost preferred.
And then someone who's just successful the first time around,
maybe,
maybe not so much in America but in person anyway,
as far as the most notable business failure that we've ever had was taking on
Coca Cola,
uh,
with Virgin Cola.
And for awhile it really looked like we were going to topple coke and Pepsi.
I mean,
we were outselling them in the UK.
The virgin brand resonated it.
People love to drink.
I mean,
and then,
you know,
we landed in Times Square with the,
with the,
with the Sherman tank and you know,
we,
we took on coke in their homeland in America and code decided too far back and
they build that,
um,
DC tens full of money and hit men and women.
And they landed in the territories that we had launched and they suddenly,
Virgin Cola started disappearing from all these shells.
And I think the lesson I learned from that was if I'm going to take on a good
liar,
I've got to be,
we've got to be different.
We've got to be much better than they are.
And you know with a Cola,
you're just another cola.
You're not,
you can't be fundamentally different.
You can be cheaper than you can't be fundamentally different.
So anything we've launched since then,
we've got,
we've only launched new businesses if we,
if we can make a fundamental difference.
I love it.
Yeah,
that's so,
so important to underscore.
I think this is the last rapid fire question,
if you,
if you could have a giant billboard anywhere with anything on it.
So,
and this is metaphorically speaking,
so getting a message out to millions or billions of people,
what would it say and why?
It could be a few words.
Could be paragraph,
could be a quote.
You live your life by yours or someone else's.
It does.
Does anything come to mind if you could get a message out to billions of people,
what would you,
what,
what might you put on that billboard?
I think I'm going to sound like
a,
um,
a muddle on stage,
peace,
peace of the world.
Uh,
and,
and therefore I will instead go back to be a businessman,
which is,
you know,
I think just something like nothing ventured,
nothing gained.
I think,
I think that in life,
if people,
you know,
people get to try things and stick their neck out,
they're going to have a lot more fun than that.
If they sitting home watching other people do it.
And I'm so,
yeah.
So I think that old,
that old quote,
nothing ventured,
nothing gained is important.
Having said that,
I,
um,
you know,
I've been involved for 10 years now in this wonderful group called the eldest
and,
um,
and Nelson Mandela set it up
and it's not run by Copia and,
and,
and I,
and I really do believe that,
uh,
in my,
in our lifetime,
I've seen so many unnecessary wars.
I've seen the Vietnamese war,
I've seen the Iraq war,
the Libyan war.
And these were all incredibly unjust wars,
which have,
you know,
gone on to some Sporn awful things like isis and so on,
which would not have happened if it wasn't for actually the West,
uh,
taking it upon themselves to interfere in other countries,
business and killing and maiming thousands of people.
And,
you know,
we,
we must make sure that we don't have any walls in the future.
And I think it takes business people,
uh,
it takes,
society,
takes all of us to really make sure that our politicians never,
never take us down that path again.
I mean,
one of the sides of things I think about the invasion of Iraq was,
you know,
yes,
there were thousands of people on the streets.
There should have been hundreds and hundreds of thousands,
just like,
uh,
the Vietnamese war two to stop such a foodish excursion.
You know,
all,
all conflicts should be able to be resolved by negotiation.
And you know,
even if you don't get exactly what you want out of it,
that is better than better than the all the bloodshed that flows from,
from conflict.
Okay.
Maria Sharapova at Maria Sharapova is the winner of five Grand Slam titles and
an Olympic silver medalist.
She is one of 10 women and the only Russian to hold a career Grand Slam,
which refers to winning all four major championships.
Wimbleton the Australian Open,
the US Open and the French Open.
Forbes also has named Maria the highest paid female athlete of all time,
which she first earned in 2005 she has held that title for more than a decade.
Okay.
Is it true that you've never used the word rejection or that you don't believe
in that word?
Is that true?
Well,
I don't,
I mean that's a very,
it's a very word to believe
in.
It's a very tough word to,
except I think one of the reasons is,
is because I,
I saw in many different scenarios where my father would say no because he would
open up an opportunity to say yes and
could you please explain?
So there are many situations,
whether it was a coaching opportunity or whether it was receiving money from an
agency,
you had this ability to say no to the things that seem that like they made
sense,
like the easy way out because he believed that later he'd have a better
opportunity to say yes to bigger and greater things.
Right.
You said no to the small shiny objects
at the time.
I'm sure they didn't seem so small.
Not Smart,
not smug smile.
That's why I'm in perception.
Right?
The short term shiny objects maybe.
Okay.
Right.
So if rejection,
it wasn't,
um,
there was never a cause I always had,
I mean I,
I always was following and kind of next to my father and seeing the decisions
that you would make a,
I was only a kid and even when I won,
I won.
Wimbledon knows only 17 years old.
You're still a kid and you're still fun following the guidance and you know,
I'd win a match falling,
then I'd call it or I'd win a tournament and I go shopping in a store and I
would call my mom cause I,
I something like quite pricey and I,
I didn't know if I could buy it.
So still asking permission,
even though I had earned that money,
if I could purchase a piece of jewelry or shoes or whatever it was at the time
that I wanted.
So I was always watching and observing and they never rejection.
I mean you're,
of course when someone says no to you,
it's easy to say,
Oh yes I was,
I was rejected.
But if you can open up a different opportunity from that point of view,
then you're turning a no into something that's,
that brought you to a better place.
It sounds like you did that with your interactions with some of the other
players who were boarding at Nick's tennis academy in a way.
Yeah.
Do you consider yourself an introvert and extrovert?
The blend?
How do you think about that?
I think from a very young age because of sort of the,
the process that I,
that I went through,
um,
and the success that I earned from a young age and winning a major and a grand
slam at such a young age.
And because it became so unexpected,
I went from being someone that was,
you know,
that someone that people scout it to being someone that everyone had analyzed
and knew about and wanted to know more of.
And I created this.
Um,
no,
I definitely put on these horse blinders because if I had not,
my mind would have been everywhere and I think it would have been so easy to be
distracted and in those moments and situations and be pulled in different
directions.
Which a Hudson,
it's a slippery slope.
It's very dangerous.
And as a young girl it could have been a disaster to say the least.
And so,
okay.
I definitely remember,
I remember the moment and it was just a few matches before I won Wimbledon where
I was sitting down with my coach and all of a sudden,
I think,
I think it was before the semifinals at that tournament and all these tourists
who had gotten credentials,
they seem like tourists.
I didn't know who they were.
Um,
maybe they would,
maybe they weren't.
Maybe they were important agents are sponsors,
but at the time they just seem like tourists that are wanted a picture with me
and,
and it really came overnight and that sense of wow,
everyone,
all of a sudden once something,
everyone wants something that you have,
everyone wants to be a part of your success.
I didn't like that feeling.
You know,
I,
I love the feeling of being in a position of,
of showcasing what I could do with my tennis racket.
But that feeling of everyone wanting a piece of that and the feeling of your
opponents,
all of a sudden all of a sudden feeling like just by beating her,
they're not just winning a quarter final of the final of the match,
but they're winning so much more.
Um,
it made me,
it made me feel like I needed to kind of put myself in a bubble to concentrate,
to focus,
that it was going to be that much harder,
that much more difficult.
And I did.
And,
um,
I don't know if I could have done it another way.
What were some of the,
or what are some of the best practices or decisions that have helped you with
that?
Because for instance,
my friend Josh,
I was mentioning earlier who became well known effectively overnight,
particularly with the movie about his life,
uh,
for chess.
He could no longer compete,
uh,
effectively after that because he would go to a chess tournament and there would
be,
um,
I'm making up the age,
but he's something like 13 or 14,
and all of a sudden they're 20 girls who want his attention and a bunch of
reporters.
And a,
he removed himself completely from the competitive scene.
He's one of the most private people I know at this point.
So what,
what helped you,
what kind of decisions or advice or practices?
I think it was surrounding myself with good minds and good people that had my
best interest.
And it's so easy to say those words,
but I know how difficult it is to find those people.
And even harder now nowadays,
and it,
and I s I saw so many different examples of other,
of other tennis players and of their success and their paths after that.
And the people that you all of a sudden associate yourself with,
I think as an individual,
it's very easy to be affected by the voices that are next to you because we
listened to that and we,
we process that information and all of a sudden we,
I won't say we want to be like them,
but we,
we,
we interpreted in,
in our way.
But like when I read,
when I read a funny book,
all of a sudden I feel like I'm a comedian or you know,
when I,
I watched this an incredible,
um,
acting by someone,
it inspires me to,
um,
to be an actor.
You know,
it's like there's moments of this that that happens as an athlete you surround
yourself with,
with people's opinions or choices or money and wealth.
And it's very,
it's such an easy distraction.
And,
and I surrounded myself with good people and I,
the friends that I have today where my friends,
when I was a young girl that my manager has managed,
knew since I was 11 years old now my mom is still very much my best friend and
another really good friend of mine I met when I was 11 years old as well.
So I have,
um,
I have this fondness of,
of developing those real connections with people.
And I think it was so helpful for me as a young girl because I competed in front
of thousands of people and I still do.
And the walk to the tunnel and the walk to a press conference and the walk back
in the hotel room.
It's a very lonely journey and that it's a difficult,
you know,
you're in your mind a lot and you're,
you're thinking a lot.
So when you have,
when you have voices next to you that are the right voices,
then it,
it's so helpful.
But I know how hard it is to find.
But I do believe that that is a big part of my success.
I have some public exposure and have found,
I've made it a lot of mistakes and found it really difficult to identify in some
cases what ulterior motives are or if people start doing the tons of favors,
I now realize there might be something coming six months later.
Uh,
so I'm very hesitant to accept favors,
but I can't even imagine the level,
I mean I'm playing tee ball and you're in the major leagues in the world series
when it comes to how many people want a piece of you and how do you,
for instance,
assess someone if you say have coffee or lunch with them,
what do you look out for or look for me?
And how do you decide whether it's someone you want to see a second time or talk
to a second?
Uh,
I,
if,
if anything comes to mind,
and this is just because quite frankly,
you've had a lot more requests.
Yeah.
Well,
no,
you've got a lot,
you've got a lot more practice and that you said,
I was like,
Whoa,
that automatic reply.
I was like,
oh my goodness.
Oh,
I don't know.
It was emailing you.
I'm afraid I have 4,091 unread email in my inbox.
Oh my goodness.
Released into the wild.
Do that.
I need to keep my inbox clean then I feel like I've a mess in my head.
All right,
well we'll talk about that next.
But in the meantime,
um,
so how do I,
I choose,
um,
I think it's about,
I love meeting people and I love having conversation and I love being inspired
and you can get so much out of a conversation or about from x by exposing
yourself to being in an unfamiliar territory.
So with people.
Um,
and I'll give you the kind of an example that was,
I felt like it was important because I'm very much,
I'm always around the same people.
So I have my team,
which is my coach and my fitness coach and my trainer.
And we travel.
I see them more than my family.
We travel probably 260 days out of the year together,
breakfast,
lunch,
dinners,
practice training.
Um,
we know so much of each other.
And then you have a manager and then you come home and then you have your
friends.
So I'm always surrounded by people that I know and that I trust and that I love,
which is incredible.
But I always think that as a,
as a human being and from the perspective of the mind and growth and um,
intellectually when you're put in a situation where you're unfamiliar with
people and you're unfamiliar with their stories or who they are and you have to
ask questions and to get that out,
it makes you a much more interesting person.
And so last year I put myself in this position,
um,
where I had all this time off and it was during the summer and I signed up for
these two business courses in Boston at Harvard business school and I was one
out of the 40 students,
I believe in each of these courses.
And I stayed on campus.
And these were individuals who were CEOs and CEOs of companies,
of airlines of Microsoft have,
um,
all these incredible brands.
And I was by far the youngest and,
and um,
probably the silliest and the least knowledgeable one in the room.
But just by being with them,
just by sitting with them,
just by sitting with them at dinner,
by asking them questions,
by feeling a little bit uncomfortable.
I felt like at the end of those three weeks I grew and I grew and,
and it wasn't that,
I mean there were definitely things that I learned that I,
I'm applying and that I wanted to apply in my business.
But the biggest thing I got out of it was that I grew as a person.
I,
I became familiar and an in a very unfamiliar territory.
I still keep in touch with people in those,
in,
in the classes.
Um,
we have completely different lives.
their CEO's of companies,
they have,
you know,
three or four kids.
Um,
you know,
they travel all over the place and here I am a 30 year old athlete,
but there's so much respect in that room because we're all trying to learn and
to grow.
And so when I,
when you asked me like,
who are the people that you want to meet with or speak to or have a coffee with,
I always think of that and the people that I choose to be with or the people
that I want to learn from and that I want to have a conversation with and not
just about what they bought at the flea market or you know,
what they're gonna,
how they're,
how they like their coffee.
But it's about the world and it's about education.
It's about people.
And,
and it's not about right or wrong,
I don't always have conversation because I want to know what makes someone
perfect and not,
I like to hear opinions.
And I got out of that experience in Boston and I know I felt like I grew,
I felt like I stepped up and I got out of my comfort zone and I followed up with
them.
And,
um,
and we still keep in touch about business and um,
projects and things like that.
So it was a very interesting experience.
Personally for me,
Vince Vaughn,
wild west on Twitter is one of the most prolific actors,
writers and producers in the world.
If he's acted in more than the 30 major motion pictures that have gone on to
grow some more than 1.7 billion at the box office.
He's largely credited for redefining the r rated comedy with this performance in
the 2005 hit wedding crashers,
which set the record for highest grossing r rated comedy at the time he is and
will continue to be.
I expect one of the most sought after leading men in Hollywood.
I met Vince because he listened to this podcast and he reached out through his
production company,
wild west to see if we might do a TV show together specifically.
He had seen,
one of my first ted talks was actually recorded at something called the Eg,
the entertainment gathering,
where I talked about language learning,
dance and swimming,
three fears that I overcame it using different toolkits with the help of mentors
and we discussed many different options and we settled on a show that ended up
being called fearless with the less in parentheses and it's in parentheses
because the objective of the show where I interviewed everyone from David
Blaine,
the illusionist and endurance artist to Kyle Maynard and Stewart Copeland of the
police and so on.
The objective was and is teach
people to fear less to words to fearless,
which is trainable,
not to be fearless,
which is not the objective at all.
You know,
one great thing about failure as you realize it's not as bad as your mind makes
it out to be and script the Ferris more crippling than the actual consequences.
The consequences a lot of times feel almost relieving in a way,
because now you've faced it,
you've gone through it,
and that kind of takes that away from,
yeah,
no,
it's,
it's amazing how also over time,
the more you,
you don't address your fear and meaning.
If you take some large fear and you break it down into the smallest possible
steps,
let's say for swimming,
for me it was even just putting my face underwater for a period of time,
right?
So forget about swimming,
forget about learning how to breathe,
just putting your face under water,
and then when you finally have the incentive,
like this bet that I had with my friend,
or rather this mutually assigned near as resolution with the deadline,
was that with a deadline with a deadline.
When I actually sat down and found a method of swimming called total immersion,
which I recommend everybody,
which was introduced to me by Chris Sacca who also had difficulty swimming and
he said,
I'm the answer to your prayers.
It took me a week,
about 10 days to go from zero laps in a pool to like 40 laps a workout as
meditation.
It was an incredibly,
it was in,
it was incredibly easy compared to the mental monster that I had created for
myself.
That's what's fascinating is how much of it is the woods that we've created
versus the actual path to the destination.
You were,
as I understand it,
uh,
rejected for certain roles because of your height.
Is that true?
I mean the leading,
uh,
leading men at the time or that the roles they were casting for or maybe the
people you'd be featured with would be shorter and the issues there that,
that,
that ended up being an issue in the early days.
I think whatever you're getting rejected for,
they find a reason to say it.
You know,
I think when I was going out for roles,
you younger and I was so much taller than people,
they would say that,
and I'm sure it played a role into it,
but I think it's important.
Whatever you're doing that you don't give voice to things that you're not able
to change,
you would have to use it in a way to find ways to do stuff.
It's all in neutral,
ultimately,
even if it doesn't feel that way on some level,
at least for the purposes of approaching stuff.
But,
you know,
look,
at the end of the day,
it's just a lot of rejection.
It's the nature of it.
So I,
I had gotten turned on,
okay,
probably a thousand to one for the Times that I would audition or more.
Um,
and it wasn't always consistent,
the reasons why,
but all you knew was that you weren't getting a chance to participate.
And so you would have to go back to the lab and try to get to a place of being
more and more undeniable.
And when you are going through all these rejections,
of course,
at a certain point,
it just becomes second nature to not flinch as much when you get turned down for
something.
But if you were giving advice,
say an
up and coming actor who has some degree of talent,
but it's getting rejected and they're,
they're really just feeling like they're getting punched in the face by the
world,
what would you say to that person?
Well,
I think I looked at it mathematically at a certain point,
which was I started just focusing my entire day on perfecting
my craft.
So it was either watching a movie,
reading a book on stuff.
I'm doing monologues,
taking classes,
and I drink products from infomercials Gordian probably for infomercials came
later.
That was the dessert.
That was a treat for him.
I've gotten a chance to work,
but I would deny myself other things.
I couldn't go do this.
I couldn't travel until I earned it.
So I would deny myself certain things that I would want to do.
Um,
and say,
you haven't earned that yet,
which I find to be a good motivator.
And then,
um,
what I did was if I would screen test for a movie that was a big opportunity,
that would have been life changing,
it would've given me an opportunity.
Uh,
what do you screen testing?
I'm just going to,
as an idiot,
I'll ask screen tests would be your close.
There's a couple of people for a role and now they're going to film a scene from
the movie with you and perhaps the Rd Kasten actor or just pair people together.
Um,
and in screen testing they would just see who mixes and matches or how do you do
on camera,
how do they feel you come off.
And I had a couple of those maybe four or five for good opportunities and when
you don't get it,
so you could go to seven or eight auditions to get to this point is between you
and two or three other people.
And when you don't get it your day,
the next day doesn't change,
meaning you still are going to get asked to go in for five lines on a television
show or something smaller.
There is no advancement as far as opportunity.
You,
you were just a person with the same credits you had.
So it was a lot of time spent to get to that in energy to get to that moment.
And if it didn't pan out,
there was no change in how someone,
you are no more castable as a known entity than what you were.
So what would happen is when you would get that close,
and it wouldn't happen at first,
I would get down and I would take four or five days and I would just not do
anything.
And I'd say all of this,
I lose my energy.
And then I started to realize that the week I took off was really two weeks that
it was a week of not getting better and it was a week of getting worse.
And I said,
now I've given myself two weeks less to improve at the things I'm in control of.
And I started looking at it like a percentage gain.
The more I worked on things,
my percentages would go up.
And what I realized later was it gave you a confidence to feel like you belong
there.
Um,
it gave you permission to perform in situations that didn't feel comfortable
because you had felt good about what you had that brought to the table.
And so I would suggest that you find a process where you're able to,
I think it's important to allow yourself to feel disappointed.
I it's important that you don't turn off those feelings,
but it is also important too.
How do you do that as quickly as possible to then become a productive again and
start doing the things that are going to give you a better opportunity for what
you want.
The same could be said for a relationship.
It hurts your feelings.
It's but how much time is the effective in mourning it processing it.
I really believe no time is not good.
You need that moment to accept it,
but the sooner you can get back to doing things for your own growth and the
things you're in charge of,
I think your chances of having the things you want in your life become greater.
I think also from what I've observed in you and other people who've done really
well in their respective fields,
is that having an opportunity to be exposed to micro failures on some
environment,
like wrestling,
like auditions inoculates you in such a way that you develop a tolerance for
rejection and that allows you to capitalize on opportunities and much more
effectively later because you don't take the two weeks off.
Right?
Correct.
And it allows you to improve.
So,
but then we have the problem on the other side,
which I don't know if you've experienced and you see it with boxers a lot,
but once you have a level of success,
can you maintain a motivation,
right.
To have the approach that you once had,
When the immediate needs are not there as strong.
Sure.
Cause I think on some level we all are looking for those things in life.
How to let go of stuff and how to enjoy things in a more productive way.
Could you talk about your car accident in high school?
Sure.
Yeah.
It's not something that we've talked about.
No,
I haven't talked about it much,
but we were,
uh,
it was after school.
I had played sports and then I had stopped.
I started getting more into acting and it was during the day and,
um,
I was a passenger in the,
and it was raining out and the girl that was driving was swerving on the road
being cute.
I remember a saying,
don't swerve,
don't,
you know,
stop it.
Uh,
but she kept doing it and we would go maybe 35 miles an hour and then we hydro
plane and I woke up in a ditch,
my thumb ripped up a real bad and I couldn't move.
My legs couldn't move.
I had paramedics over me and I have blood all around me.
I was real concerned.
My friend,
I,
I didn't have any idea how I looked.
I wasn't tracking it,
but my friend was real bloody.
I said it Sean.
Okay.
They said,
yeah,
he's all right.
They got me in the ambulance and then they couldn't get ahold of my parents at
first cause they were worth traveling.
And so I just remember being in a lot of pain.
Um,
there was a moment you didn't know what the ramifications were.
I had a small compression,
which turned out to be nothing in my back.
But,
uh,
and,
the aesthetic of my thumb being injured,
I,
at the time I didn't,
I mean it's now just a very bad scar on the backside of it.
And thankfully I have the thumb and can move it,
but there's a pad that was gone.
So,
uh,
that was,
um,
that was challenging because it really made me evaluate the oldest cliche,
you know,
without your health,
you don't have anything.
So I really got the experience of feeling like,
well,
what if I can't move around or people go outside and play and things I had taken
for granted.
Um,
and then this,
the anything physical that is different that you're used to in a certain way.
I think at first it's a national to feel insecure about it.
And here I was at that time knowing one to pursue being an actor,
an entertainer.
So it was a gift in,
you know,
um,
processing things and putting your focus on other things.
And you started to realize the power of your own inner dialogue as far as what
you were creating or not.
So there was a lot of gifts in it ultimately,
but at the time it was,
I feel lucky for it and that it was without real consequences.
It was a,
it was a nice learning a gift in a way
suggest to,
we're going to talk a lot about that inner dialogue and self talk,
but I don't want to touch on a few things that are around that same time period.
And as maybe a preface to that,
I will say that Vince is one of the most consistently curious people I've ever
met,
which is saying a lot because my job is to interview curious people and give you
an idea.
We were just backstage,
uh,
getting miked up and he had questions about something called the Marcello teen.
So Marcello teen is a choke that's used in Brazilian Jujitsu by the Michael
Jordan slash Wayne Gretzky of grappling.
His name is Marcello Garcia.
So I was backstage choking vents that 10 minutes ago and there were a lot of
very nervous look
very effectively.
I will,
it's a good joke.
Marcella knows what he's doing.
And,
uh,
grappling was one of the first things,
wrestling specifically that we bonded over.
And could you talk about the role of sports
and wrestling to the extent that it's,
that it had a lasting impact?
I think it's important.
I think,
you know,
George Washington,
I think credited ballroom dancing and horseback riding is two of the most
important things he did because it gave him confidence physically and grace.
And,
you know,
being a leader,
I don't know that you can put grace in the body without,
you know,
whether it's,
I took ballet,
I took,
played sports.
I think it's important,
um,
especially for me being tall.
It allowed me to have,
I think more control and confidence in my,
and my,
um,
my height.
And,
and,
uh,
so wrestling to me was really a course in resiliency and discipline.
Uh,
I would have loved to have played other team sports,
but it was,
I was very good at wrestling for whatever reason,
and I wasn't as accepted in some of the team sports.
So wrestling is very much a loner sport.
Um,
if you're on a team bus,
you kind of joke around and laugh on a wrestling bus.
Everyone is dead side.
Partially because they're all dehydrated from cutting weight,
cutting weight,
and you're going to get in a fight in front of your school or people you don't
know.
It's like you shake hands in,
it's like you're gone.
You know,
there's no one missed a block.
You've got,
you've got beat right and you are dehydrated.
It's auditing and that you're growing and yet you're trying to maintain a weight
as,
I mean it's,
especially when you're doing it when you're younger,
it's very challenging.
But I really felt that I got,
and there's,
you know,
you would come out of playing football feeling like you were in shape and then
you would go and wrestling and you would realize you're not in any kind of shape
because if you just wrestle,
it's exhausting.
And then the only other thing you can do is run.
And in the winter in Illinois,
that meant hallways and stairs.
We had a coach that was,
he got fired.
He was not fit to be with kids,
but I felt like I was fuck,
I benefited from having that personality,
but he was a real problem.
But I remember,
I feel like we need a little more elaborate than that in some people's minds
don't go crazy.
Well,
he was,
uh,
he had a real anger problem.
He would hit okay.
I got hit and it says in spotlight,
I just want him.
Yeah,
he punched me once in the chest after a match.
You hit the wind out of me.
He would,
he encouraged kids hurting each other,
but it seemed normal at the time.
You know?
Uh,
he was like the Cobra Kai.
Yeah.
It was like Cobra Kai.
It was crazy.
He had his own emotional issues.
So we would win a meat like 60 to six or whatever it was,
and he would be angry over the few mistakes and he would,
it was at some point you just heard the emotion being poured on.
You remember his sister was in the assistant.
He'd always say,
get me a tab in an aspirin or an Advil.
Go give me my,
go get me a tab and half Advil and it needs to keep screaming at us.
But uh,
he would sometimes,
like there was a,
you know,
we would run these stairs and he would say in these hallways,
it was,
it was like a spread,
but you didn't make it under a minute 20,
you would add another one.
Right.
And he was intentionally,
you were going to have the bar moved and he was trying to break your spirit.
He wanted to simulate,
all is lost.
What you thought was going to get you there is not,
and that will you stand.
Right.
Um,
but inevitably the second string heavyweight was number going to make that time.
So the first time he would do it,
you'd say,
okay,
he's called the kid's name real loud was a Illinois.
So it was either,
I think it was a,
I remember the name,
I won't say it,
but it might've been like eastern European last name.
And he said,
uh,
he was late.
So then the first time we could run after that,
there'd be some encouragement.
Come on,
you could do it.
But the second or third time kids would start yelling and screaming at him or
kicking at them and really physically forcing him.
It was like a,
like a bad episode,
like a bad,
a few good men.
It was terrible.
Uh,
and I always had a problem with a third Doroty anyway,
and I clashed with him a lot.
I ended up just showing up at the meets and I was good enough that I could do
that.
I wouldn't go to practices all the time.
I really had problems with him,
but he did punch me one time when the chassis,
but he turned to be someone that created a past that was not truthful.
He had told us that he made the Olympic team,
but that it was when the year that we boycotted it
turned out not to be true,
you know?
But anyway,
I guess the long version of it is,
I think that I gained a lot more than I lost even with him being um,
uh,
challenging and a lot of ways I wouldn't change that experience.
You can have a great coach,
which there are in wrestling and I think in general,
one of the great attributes of wrestling is a constitution and a grit.
The ability to survive painful moments and not take them on in the absolute
sense,
meaning to have perspective on pain.
Caroline Paul at a Kero Writers,
c a r o writer on Twitter is an author,
fiction and nonfiction.
She worked in public radio as a journalist before joining the San Francisco Fire
Department in 1988 is one of their first female firefighters.
She worked most of her career on rescue too,
where she and the crew were responsible for search and rescue and fires.
Rescue two members were also trained and sent on scuba searches.
She has some horrifying stories of pulling out,
decomposing bodies,
rope and repelling rescues,
surf rescues,
confined space searches,
all hazardous material calls,
and the most severe train and car wrecks.
Her first book was the nonfiction memoir fighting fire published in 1998 she
also wrote the New York Times bestseller and a book that I think is fantastic
called the gutsy girl.
She calls it lean in for girls,
but I think it's actually much more than that and it's not set in the boardroom,
but rather in trees on cliff edges and in wild rivers.
She's very,
very good at recognizing how resilience and toughness gutsiness can be trained.
It can be taught,
and in a commercial New York Times Essay,
the proceeded publication of that book she wrote that risk teaches kids
responsibility,
problem solving and confidence.
You can certainly find it very easily by searching Caroline Paul New York Times,
her perspective on fear and how she overcomes it in the most extreme
circumstances,
she's done losing.
She's done all sorts of extreme sports.
Her approach was extremely helpful and inspiring and valuable to me personally,
and I hope the same for you.
When you think of the moments you've been most terrified.
Yeah.
What are those moments that come to mind?
They don't have to be physical danger.
They could be,
but what are,
what are the moments that first come to mind for you?
Okay.
Well,
I think the time that I was probably the most physically scared and it was a bit
of an unusual feeling for me,
and I'm not trying to say that I'm super brave,
I just had this ability to really take fear and put it way,
way back in line of all my other emotions when I was a,
uh,
but I was in a,
I talk about this in the book actually,
I was in a fire building and I was with my crew and I was,
we're in teams of two.
So the,
the,
the team who was ahead of me,
frank and Andy,
and then I had,
my crewmate was behind me,
victor,
he and I were together,
but we were all crawling down the same hallway and we had a hose line,
which was unusual,
but they couldn't find the fire.
So the chief goes,
hey guys,
we,
you guys grab a hose line.
So we're psyched to do that.
It's awesome to go find the heat,
the seat of the fire,
and it's super smoky,
hot and kind of quiet in this weird way.
And then all of a sudden a huge explosion which pushed us all out of the hallway
and we're,
what we realized later was that there had been a flashover not in the hallway,
which would have killed us,
but somewhere close enough by to just massage over a flashover is when the room
gets so hot that even the particles in the air simultaneously ignite.
So it's basically this just huge.
It's like a gas plus basically.
Yeah,
I've been in those two and those are not,
those are,
we'll knock your mask off and throw you backwards.
And I remember being sort of discombobulated and in the garage and my friend
frank goes,
where's victor?
Victor was my,
my crew mate.
And I look around and there was just three of us instead of four.
And I remember thinking,
I have to go back into that hallway.
And the,
the fear was paralyzing this all tooks milliseconds.
And I see frank,
who's super brave,
really great firefighter,
just turn and start to just catapult himself towards that door to find victor.
And for me,
it was only a millisecond,
but I was scared.
And I recognize that fear and that fear scared me more than the fear itself.
Because when you're paralyzed as a firefighter and your friend is missing that,
that's the worst.
And so of course I was right on his heels,
but I,
that feeling of overwhelming fear was really sobering for me.
And,
uh,
but what I learned of course is that you can be scared.
That's okay,
but you still have to take action if it's necessary.
And then my friend was fine.
He had actually been blown out too,
but he,
he took shelter on the other side and we,
we were found ourselves in the garage.
So it all ended up fine.
But it was a moment I'll never forget.
So you've,
you've mentioned,
uh,
in your writing for instance,
the,
your ability to put fear behind your other emotions.
And the story that comes to mind for me is the,
uh,
and we,
we don't necessarily have to go into the details of this right now,
the climbing
of the Golden Gate Bridge,
which by the way,
folks list saying illegal.
I wouldn't recommend doing it now after 2001.
Yeah,
they will shoot you.
They will shoot you.
So not involved in the 90 [inaudible] but not anymore.
Uh,
760 some odd feet or something along those lines.
70,
maybe,
maybe 720.
I don't know.
You probably have better,
better memory of the elevation than I,
but uh,
where did you develop that ability or how did you develop that ability?
Like for someone listening is like,
God,
you know,
I'm so fearful.
How can I develop that same ability to take,
say courage or desire or whatever it might be,
enthusiasm and try to put it in front of this dominant emotion that I have and
default emotion,
which is fear.
What would you,
what would you say to them,
and I guess it's two questions.
How do you develop it and what would you say to them?
But you can tackle it any way you'd like?
Well,
I am not against fear.
Let me just say right up front.
I think fear is,
it is definitely important.
It's there to keep us safe,
but I do feel like some people give it too much priority.
It's one of the many
things that we use to assess the situation.
Um,
so I'm not against fear,
but I am pro bravery.
So that's my paradigm.
So once I know that fear is just one of many things that are going on.
So for instance,
when we climbed the bridge,
which was five of us deciding we wanted to walk up that cable in the middle of
the night,
please don't do that.
But,
uh,
we did and it was a really,
I mean,
talk about fear.
you're working on a cable.
We have to put one foot in front of the other and you get higher and higher
until you're basically uh,
uh,
honest as high as a 70 story building and with nothing below you and holding on
to these two thin wires on either side.
It's just a walk.
Technically,
really nothing's going to happen unless some earthquake or sudden catastrophic
gust of wind,
which was really not going to happen.
You're going to be fine as long as you keep your mental state intact.
Don't panic.
It's just a walk.
And so what I do in those situations is I look and look at all the emotions I'm
feeling,
which is anticipation,
exhilaration,
focus,
confidence,
fun and fear.
And then I take fear and say,
well,
how much priority am I going to give this?
I really want to do this.
And then I put it where it belongs.
And it's,
it's kind of like brick laying.
I Dunno.
You just look at all the bricks and you were making a stone wall.
You fit the pieces together.
So do you,
or have you literally,
I should use that word core carefully in my life in general,
but visualized the bricks or I'd like to someone who hasn't had this practice.
Okay.
And you're going to give them sort of a,
uh,
a meditation exercise,
right?
The next time you're feeling fear.
Do this.
How,
what would you advise them to do?
Yeah,
I actually want someone until partition each emotion as if it's a little
separate block and then put it in a line.
Because once you not only look at your emotions,
but also assess your own skill and the situation,
often things change.
I mean we're scared.
Supposedly.
I hear people say,
I'm so scared of fill in the blank,
picking up an insect.
Really what is really so scary about an insect?
Seriously,
is it going to eat?
You know,
so as long as you stop and really look,
I think people's lives will change kind of radically,
especially for women because women are very,
very quick to say they're scared and that's something I really want to change.
This is Caroline Paul and I'm really happy to be back with all of you and Tim on
the Tim Ferriss podcast for round two and you sent me a bunch of questions and
I'm going to answer some of them.
Thanks so much.
Let's just dive right in.
So no name asked.
If you're trying to change your relationship with fear,
where do you start?
It's hard to face it when it's breathing down on you.
Any tips?
Well first of all,
congratulations on changing your relationship to fear.
I don't know if you're a woman,
but if you are,
this is an especially big step because as I've talked about,
I feel really strongly that we as women have been so encouraged to be fearful
that it's an underpinning of our life that we're often not even conscious of.
So just taking this step is amazing.
Here's my tip.
It's really straight forward micro bravery because here's a concept that a great
organization calls girls leadership.
Really articulate it to me,
which is that bravery is learned and like anything learned,
it just needs to be practiced.
And the way we practice things is to start small.
So micro bravery,
this is what they call it.
I love that microbe Avery is basically breaking down,
um,
your fears into either smaller steps or just start starting small with any fear.
And the reason we want to do that is because,
well,
first of all,
you become aware of what it feels like to be fearful.
Because here's the truth,
and I think I talked about this on the podcast before,
but fear feels a lot like excitement has the same physiological characteristics,
you know,
high heart rate,
the sweat,
nervous tension.
And so often what we do,
especially as women,
because we're really not taught to discern the nuances of fear because we aren't
taught to value bravery like men are.
So we aren't taught to really move through it,
uh,
is that it feels so similar to excitement that we often mistake the fact that we
are not actually completely subsumed with abject fear.
We actually are feeling fear and other things,
excitement,
exhilaration,
anticipation,
curiosity,
things that really will open up our life.
And that actually is telling us,
hey,
this,
this new experience is going to be kind of cool.
But because,
and again,
often it's women.
We don't,
we haven't practiced bravery,
so we don't really understand what we're feeling in times of stress or where
we're pushing outside.
We're comfort zone.
So when you practice bravery and really what you're practicing is micro bravery,
you get really comfortable and you start to understand what fear feels like.
And you start to discern all the nuances of that emotion.
So the second thing you become knowledgeable about is,
uh,
what bravery is.
Because I think a lot of women don't really have a sense of what that feels like
either.
In fact,
I like to,
to turn around maybe even this question and say,
well,
it's not really changing your relationship to fear.
It's changing your relationship to bravery.
And so what we're doing,
and I know I talked about this before,
is that we are valuing a bravery paradigm instead of a v a fear paradigm.
Because I do think we give permission to women to talk about fear a lot.
And um,
to really emphasize it in ways that make it,
um,
that perpetuates it.
The last thing you do is when you're practicing Micah bravery,
you really start to develop a process of moving from fear to bravery.
And that process,
when you use it in small instances,
you can apply when you confront fear in bigger instances.
And that can be an emotional fear.
And that can be fear at a,
you know,
in,
in your workplace.
And that can also be fear in the outdoors.
Now when you practice micro bravery,
I really want kids to practice it in the outdoors because it's really fun,
the outdoors and it's a really great way to understand,
uh,
that line between being scared and then excitement and then going to bravery
because it's just more obvious than if you're trying to practice in a more
emotional situation.
But as adults,
I you already know whether you like the outdoors or not,
this is not about like,
oh,
you have to be in the outdoors to be brave,
not true.
You guys who are not so much outdoors,
he can practice in,
uh,
at home or in the workplace,
small acts of micro bravery.
Again,
really important.
This is something you start small so that you really get to know yourself and
bravery better.
And analogy might be deciding you were going to run a five k.
You don't just go run a five k on the day of the race.
You practice and you practice in small increments.
You start by walking,
you start by,
then you proceed to running a little bit.
You get the picture.
So it's you breaking it down and in that way you're training and you're training
to understand your body like a runner and you're trading to understand your own
mind.
Well,
there you have it folks.
I hope you enjoyed this episode on overcoming or managing or perhaps even using
fear doesn't have to be a negative.
It can be something that is useful,
it can be a fuel,
it can be a call to action,
and now I'm going to pass the mic over to you guys.
Please let me know what you liked or disliked about this episode.
Let me know what you want to hear more about.
What topics would you like me to explore.
You can shoot me a note on Twitter at t Ferris,
t f,
e R R,
I s.
S or leave a comment on the blog at tim.blog/podcast and you can find the show
notes for this episode.
Until next time.
Thank you all so much.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you will get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by legal zoom.
I have used legal zoom myself for many of my businesses and many of the icons on
this podcast have actually used legal zoom.
For instance,
Matt Mullenweg of wordpress fame see of automatic,
which is now worth more a billion dollars first incorporated his company on
legal zoom.
Legal Zoom is a reliable resource that more than a million people have already
trusted to help with their businesses.
Whether that's setting up a will,
doing a proper trademark search,
forming an LLC,
setting up a nonprofit or finding simple cease and desist letter templates.
Man,
do I use a lot of those?
Legal Zoom is not a law firm,
but they do have a network of independent attorneys available in most states.
They can give you advice on the best way to get started,
provide contract reviews and otherwise help you run your business and important,
there are no surprises.
Legal Zoom provides complete transparency.
That means upfront pricing,
customer reviews,
and a satisfaction guarantee.
Check out legal zoom.com today to see how they can make life better and easier
for you and your business.
If you're pretending to be a lawyer on the Internet,
then you are asking for trouble.
Put together the safety nets.
Get your t's crossed and your I's dotted.
Enter Promo Code Tim tim@legalzoom.com to save 15% that's t I m for 15% off.
Check it out.
Legal zoom.com
this episode is brought to you by wordpress.com I love wordpress.
I have used it for so many years.
It's my goto platform for blogging and creating websites.
I use wordpress.com for everything every day.
My site tim.blog is built on it.
The websites for my books,
including tools of titans,
tribe of mentors.
It's all on wordpress.com and the founder Matt Mullenweg.
One of my close friends has appeared on the show many times.
Just search Matt Mullenweg,
Tequila Ferris for quite an exciting time.
Whether you're looking to create a personal blog,
a business site,
or both,
you can make a really big impact right out of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and you'll be in good company.
It's used by the New Yorker,
Jay Z.
Beyonce,
five 38 tech crunch,
Ted,
CNN,
and time just to name a handful,
and one of my friends@googlewhoshallremainnamelesshastoldmethatwordpress.com
offers the best out of the box SEO imaginable and quote,
and that's one of the many reasons that nearly 30% of the Internet is run on
wordpress.
You do not need experience or to hire someone that's perhaps the best part.
wordpress.com guide you through the entire experience.
They have hundreds of designs and templates that you can use and it's easy to
get started.
There's no need to worry about security upgrades,
hosting any of that.
They for 24 seven support and they're very,
very responsive.
If you have questions,
they get right back to you.
And this allows you to create the highest quality with the least amount of
headache and friction.
So if you're building a website,
period,
when my friends come to me and ask what I use,
what I recommend they use,
the answer is wordpress.com so check it out.
If you want to get started today,
learn more with a 15%
off any new plan,
go to wordpress.com forward slash Tim to create your website and find the plan
that's right for you.
So learn more.
Take a look,
wordpress.com forward slash Tim for 15% off a brand new website.
Check it out.
Alright.
Check it out right.